alors on va maintenant justement par les
drs ma famille a besoin des démissions
des filets sur nrj 12
pascal a pour mission de venir en aide à
amendis d' amandine mais vous allez voir
que dès son arrivée la jeune fille
devient complètement incontrôlable voilà
c'est mon kiff ça tous les dimanches
soirs regardez croyez pas que c'est
sébastien où on verra quelle sera leur
nom fait pas peur mais bon on n'a pas
parlé de passe et a peur qu'il arrive
seul derrière son écran train de
regarder je pense qu'il va brouiller un
peu dingue ça tu veux dire en face
[Musique]
on ne te parler moi voilà donc c'était
chaud c'était chaud et juste on avait
aussi que calcul mental voilà amandine
c'était pas ça non pas six mais voilà
c'était pas sa spécialité et vous allez
voir même pascal nom revient pas mais
après ça se finit bien comme des huîtres
regarder tout ça rien c'est ta
souffrance et imagine donc écoute bien
14 kg
[Musique]
plus 10 kilos ça fait quand même
kg + 10 kg sait trop combien 14 plus dix
cantons temps mancka très bien 24 +6
28,4 +6 ma cocotte réfléchi dans la
nasse 30
oui petit pelé par 2 30 + 30 à 60
oui alors et mathew tait une petite info
là-dessus oui parce que je suis un petit
peu gêné par la tnt ça n'a pas être la
poubelle de dire tiens c'est vrai que
j'ai pu beaucoup d'argent la télé mais
pascal thought and put sur la chaîne me
disait tout ce qui passe le dimanche
soir sur sur nrj12 et j'ai rien contre
cette chaîne j'adore ont 5 ans minimum 5
ans ou s'il ya les voilà il ya un moment
voilà donc cédé roddick terreau de céret
coup ça fait toujours du bien moins cher
ouvre à vous et vous êtes bons en calcul
mental ça peut aller
allez-y 14 plus 13 14 13 20
je veux y aller en étant dépassé à la
barre des 30
non c'est pas le juste prix 14e +13 et
-28 s'agit du set 16 plus 17
alors je dois à j'ai compris ton truc
c'est quoi alors ça fait treize les
trois plus un je dirais pas ça fait 57
ça se faisait ça fait hautement oui
[Rires]
cette couleur 16 17 alors à temps allez
allez attention je te laisse 10 sur 10
tu as 10-13 avant plus du css plus 17 16
+ 17 17 10 seront rabotées aviv 1 d'un
autre fait pourquoi
ça veut dire que tu peux lui mettre ce
que tu veux sur son chèque il s'en fout
mais tu peux lui mettre n'importe quoi